KARIM LAKHANI: Noubar Afeyan, thank
you very much for joining our course.
Please tell us a bit more about
yourself and your role as CEO
and founder of Flagship Pioneering.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Sure.
Well thanks for inviting me.
So I've been involved in
innovation and entrepreneurship
in the life sciences for about 31 years.
I did a PhD in what was then a
new field by chemical engineering.
And since then have found
different ways of deriving value
from making breakthroughs in that area.
And initially, I followed
the kind of traditional route
of developing technologies,
raising capital, and developing
startup companies, venture
backed startup companies.
And then, more recently what Flagship
Pioneering really specializes in
is in a different way of thinking about
both innovation and entrepreneurship.
And we are looking to systematize
the process and make it something
that an institution can do
instead of a group of individuals.
KARIM LAKHANI: Great.
So tell me first how you got the bug of
taking technologies and bringing them
to market.
What was the spark that got you into--
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Well different people
are inspired by different things.
In my case, it was
actually quite memorable.
I had no intention or no idea
in 1985 graduate students
let alone kind of not from this country
didn't exactly think that they were
going to go off and start a company.
That's a pretty recent phenomenon
in the last 15 years or so.
But so I was a graduate student working
in a pretty esoteric kind of project.
And I happened to find myself at an
NSF conference that MIT had sent me to.
You have to remember,
in the 1980s the US was
worried that it was going to lose
its competitiveness against Japan.
And there were all these
kind of meetings about,
how are we going to compete with Japan?
Et cetera.
And they must have needed somebody
who knew how to spell biotechnology.
So they sent me down.
And at this conference, which
was otherwise utterly boring,
I happened at lunch
to sit with somebody.
And I got enough courage to ask him
what he did and who he was and stuff.
And he started telling me how
he had started a company some 35
years earlier with another friend of his
and they were a new breed of engineer.
This was electronic engineer.
They came out of the power industry.
And I was listening to his story.
And this is kind of I
had nothing to relate to,
except when he said
new breed of engineer.
I kind of thought, well,
that's interesting.
I'm a new breed of engineer.
And engineers had not done
biology ever in the past.
And he said they didn't know
what these engineers would
make but they knew they would need
to measure whatever they made.
And so, he and his friend
of his started this effort
to make an oscilloscope in their garage.
And they started selling
it to their friends.
And then, that led them to
make even more products.
And so it's kind of interesting.
I had no idea who he was.
And but it was interesting to relate
to I was a new breed of engineer.
We didn't know what biological
engineers would make.
But we did know that they were
going to need to measure things.
And so, probably out of a
deficiency of fairly linear thinking
as engineers sometimes have,
I was just mapping it to me.
And I was thinking,
oh that's interesting.
And then I asked him who he was and it
was David Packard from Hewlett Packard.
And he spent the next couple of hours
telling me just one on one just out of,
I could have been sitting on
a park bench with the guy.
I mean he was literally
just very relatable.
And literally I came back to
MIT to my graduate kind of lab.
And then, I thought, well, how am I
going to figure out how to do this?
I really wanted to do this.
And I went to Sloan School
and said, can I take courses?
They had absolutely no courses
on entrepreneurship at the time.
Now, everybody has 1,000 courses.
But it was not something
that was taught.
So that's when I actually started
finding my way to Eric von Hippel's
class and to several other people's
class who were teaching management
of technology, innovation, there
was a corporate venture capital
course I took.
I don't know why.
All to just kind of get
myself introduced to that.
And that's kind of how I started.
KARIM LAKHANI: That's incredible.
So David Packard was the
source of your inspiration.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: It was.
Randomly.
Because he was relatable.
It's kind of one of the things I've
learned over all these years I've
done this is that sometimes people make
entrepreneurship some kind of almost
like art or science or there's
almost celebrity associated with it.
And I always resent that
because it makes it unrelatable.
It makes it look like--
I like playing basketball.
But when I look at Michael Jordan
I realize I'm not going to be him.
And those kinds of celebrity
figures don't encourage the sport.
They actually discourage the sport.
I mean, without wanting because you're
saying, I'm never going to be that.
Well he was a guy who was clearly
a celebrity in doing that.
But he was absolutely no different.
And what he impressed upon me is that if
I was willing to kind of stick with it
and iterate and learn and adapt, he
didn't give me any other tidbits.
There wasn't that much to give.
So I think, and then since
then, part of the reason
I teach, and I've taught
for the last 17 years
various aspects of entrepreneurship
innovation is just that.
Because I realized the
more people realize
that this is not some kind of highbrowed
activity, the better the economy is.
KARIM LAKHANI: So tell me from that
inspiration to your first startup.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: In 1987, which was a
couple of years after this meeting,
after I had kind of exposed myself
a little bit to what innovation
and technology was, and without really
an idea to start a company around,
as I was getting close to
graduating I started thinking,
well I should really keep that
as an alternative in mind.
I went out and met a startup company
that was then just forming out
in the West Coast, realized
that being employed in one
wasn't kind of the same thing for me
because I realized other people were
trying to figure out what needed to
be done and I was going to execute it.
And while that was
interesting that I didn't
consider that to be the same thing.
And so, I started I started kind
of trying to figure out, OK.
If I was going to do this,
what would I do it with?
And pretty linearly, I thought, OK.
What about making instruments for the
biotech industry just like these guys
have instruments for the
electronics industry?
And I started looking at, OK.
Well what the needs are?
So it gets kind of pretty kind
of classical way of thinking
about unmet needs first,
which again for a technologist
wasn't the first thought
that comes to mind.
But the folks at Sloan
impressed upon me that far more
interesting than finding
customers for what I could do
was finding problems
that were worth solving.
And so, I looked at a
bunch of different things
where we could apply engineering
mindset problem solving.
And there were many because
the field is so new.
I always find that if you're working
in a field that's rapidly changing,
there's an innate advantage
that if you're a newcomer
there isn't that much difference
between you and the current players
because they also haven't
been at it that long.
So that's how I started.
So I basically wrote a business
plan as I was graduating from MIT.
My first meeting with
a venture capitalist
was, I think it was something like
October 20, 30, or something like that.
29th, I forget the exact date in
1987, which I remember very well.
It was a Tuesday because it was the day
right after the stock market crashed.
So the Black Monday that that occurred--
KARIM LAKHANI: That was October 19.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: October 19.
So it was the day after.
October 20.
And I remember having
set up a meeting going
to see a at the time famous venture
capitalist Ginger Moore at Oak Ventures
who in the life sciences area was
one of very few people who invested.
And yeah.
I went to see her and it was
kind of quite a stark memory
because I was 24 years old
and I had the business plan
and I didn't know what I was doing.
And here was this person who had
done this for 20 years already.
And she was completely
frazzled, lost, kind of
devastated at what was going on.
And I thought, boy.
It's a weird introduction to the field.
It was the best thing that happened
to me because frankly, 31 years later,
even in the last few days,
the feeling is quite similar.
And so, one thing I learned back
then is that if you have a calm day
it's actually out of character.
But it's usually just very turbulent.
But anyway, and it also tested me.
Because her advice to me was,
you look like you can do this.
You've got a good idea.
But you're never going to be able
to raise money for the next year.
Go do something else.
Because the market had been devastated.
KARIM LAKHANI: Interesting.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: And it was interesting.
And so, that forced me to--
I didn't take her advice.
But at the same time I did realize
it was going to take a while
to be able to raise money.
And so, I started trying to--
I got a side job at MIT doing
technology licensing for a year.
My professor was generous to
kind of they needed somebody
to do some licensing work.
And I'd continued to develop the
business plan and got a lot of help
from Ed Roberts who's a kind of quite
a legendary figure in entrepreneurship.
And about, let's say maybe
almost a year later, I
ended up getting some seed capital
from quite unlikely sources,
meaning just random people I had met.
100 different people.
I used to think, and this may
be useful for your audience,
at the time I used to think that
if I'm just successful ultimately--
I felt like a beggar.
I mean that's kind of
what it feels like.
I had absolutely nothing.
I had no technology.
I had a piece of paper.
I had my background.
KARIM LAKHANI: Just the idea.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Just the idea.
There was no proof of concept, there was
no technology I was licensing, nothing.
I had an idea.
I had filed a patent.
And it was the closest thing to begging.
They have it, you don't.
You need it, they may
not need it as much.
And the chance that I'm going to give
you [INAUDIBLE] back is pretty dubious.
A similar act.
And I was telling myself,
if you're successful
then you don't have to beg anymore.
And 31 years later I
realized that if you're
successful you beg for more and more.
But that feeling doesn't go
away because any time you're
trying to kind of pre-sell the
value promise of innovation that
isn't proven, and then eventually
realize it and reward people,
it's an extreme form of fundraising.
And that's kind of what
comes with the territory.
So I ended up getting some seed capital
and started this company which ended up
growing over some period of time.
By '89, we raised some
venture capital money.
This was, again, the old days of
where venture capitalists used
to put $100,000, $300,000 in.
And then, at the most a
million, $2 million in ever.
There was not seed capital.
Seed capital back then was $25,000.
So at the end, this company called
Perceptive Biosystems ended up
raising $11 million from
seven venture capital
firms of which some
venerable firms like Venrock,
and Bessemer, and Highland
Capital were the big investors.
And 3i, the Bank of
England, I mean it was crazy
that they were all putting in
a half a million, $1 million.
And ultimately, the
company actually took off.
In '92 we went public.
In '97, we had about
$110 million in revenue.
So we became a very established
player and leader in the protein
analytical instrument field.
And so, that was that journey.
It was every day was as
exhilarating as it was terrifying.
And now, this is a well trodden road.
But back then, I remember very clearly
the most recent company that Inc. 500--
we were around the Inc.
500 pretty early on--
had featured was Lotus.
And of course lotus had subsequently
kind of been sold and disbanded.
And before that, it was digital.
So it wasn't like there were
all that many companies to say,
I want to do that.
You had to figure it out yourself.
KARIM LAKHANI: Yeah.
That's an incredible story.
So you went on this journey, you
have an idea, you incubate the idea,
you persist, form a team, you
raise capital, you go public,
then you're back for more.
So it's not one and done for you.
This has become a lifetime.
This is your-- so tell
us this transformation.
So what that was and what caused
you to sort of think about this.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Sure.
Well so first, I'll go back
to the Perceptive thing
because one of the things you
realize is that I ended up wanting--
I mean I did this
largely because I wanted
to learn how to do it as opposed
to the rewards of doing it
or a lot of other things.
I just thought it was so
unlikely that I could pick up
the minimum needed to be
able to succeed minimally
that that was a real adventure.
So I wasn't a good manager, and
probably still not a good manager,
I didn't know how to raise money,
I didn't know how to hire people,
I knew even less about
how to fire people.
Excruciatingly painful
to do for the first time.
I had hired a bunch of
experienced people early on.
The one thing I learned
that I think is quite kind
of ageless in terms of a
lesson, I use it to this day,
is that especially when you're young and
when you're not expected to know much,
the fact that you actually use that
to ingratiate yourself to people
so that they help you in
helping you figure out something
is a really powerful source
of kind of borrowed intellect.
I mean you just you cannot
have wisdom early on.
The next best thing is to admit it
and to let other people give you
their wisdom.
And by this I don't mean
advisors and mentors.
I just mean people who just
kind of like you and decide
that they want to help you succeed.
There's a lot of people
out there who as long
as you give them this
permission marketing,
this is like permission advice.
If you give them the permission to give
you advice and they see you use it,
not that they go, OK.
I'll take that into consideration.
But you truly kind of let
go of pretending that a lot.
And I didn't have this
problem because I literally
didn't know a lot about anything.
My PhD had nothing to do with what the
company did, and I knew the language,
but not much.
I had no connections.
I was an immigrant.
I came originally from Lebanon,
escaped the war, went to Canada,
kind of grew up in a foreign place.
So I had zero expectations.
Zero entitlement.
I was not even American, I was Canadian.
There was a lot of immigration
issues back then for different kind.
It was very hard to get papers here.
There was no-- H1
visas were a new thing.
And so, it's interesting in
hindsight when you look at it.
But anyway, so learning how to manage,
how to create business strategy,
I never-- to this day
I don't quite know what
strategy is when it comes
to a startup because you
have 100 different things you could do
and 100 different ways of doing them.
And choosing one I suppose is strategy.
KARIM LAKHANI: Yes.
Strategy is about choice.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: It's about choice.
But in this case, there's nothing else.
It's a bit of an arbitrary choice
in the beginning, uninformed choice,
followed by lots of iteration.
That's what I've learned.
Anyway, so and but
before getting to kind
of what I do now, what ended
up happening is in '94 or so,
this company, I had iterated
enough and made enough mistakes
that I had a pretty good team.
The revenues were growing,
we were expanding.
And for the first time I
started realizing that, OK.
I kind of sort of get it.
And I became interested in
innovation and value creation again.
And I realized that
in this company, which
was by that time about 400
people, it's really hard
to get rewarded for innovation
because even though we were little,
we were already too big.
KARIM LAKHANI: You
were already focused--
NOUBAR AFEYAN: For that.
We had a line of products.
And there's so much
more we could have done.
So I started actually experimenting
with innovating with other people
and helping other
people start companies.
So I was still running this first
company as CEO of a public company,
but I was able to, and when my board
knew it and were in support of it,
I was able to get involved
in a few other companies
that where people were either
they had a notion or an idea.
But by now I was a little experienced.
And so, ironically they were
looking for my experience.
And here I was still winging it.
And so, in the '90s kind
of between '94 and '97
I got involved in about four other
roles as a co-founder of companies.
One was a drug discovery company
that I ended up being chairman of.
And then we raised capital from a
number of other venture capitalists
to grow a very successful company.
It was sold.
We started a cancer diagnostics company,
started a cancer vaccine company.
And I found--
KARIM LAKHANI: This
sounds like an addiction.
You were just starting companies
NOUBAR AFEYAN: It was interesting.
No, I'll tell you.
This was interesting.
I was not doing it alone.
So I had gone from
founder to co-founder.
And co-founder is a more
scalable role than founder.
But at the same time, but I was
not an investor in these things.
I hadn't taken any money
out of my first company.
But I'll tell you why I got interested
in this, is that at the time
the only kind of entrepreneur there was
one and done or a serial entrepreneur.
And I had thought kind of skeptically
around serial entrepreneurship.
I didn't know anything.
But I always thought,
well, if you built a lot
of value, what is there to show by
doing it again, and again, and again?
A silly thought.
So I thought what about
parallel entrepreneurship?
And back in the '90s I used
to go around and tell people,
entrepreneurship should be parallel.
It's like parallel chess where people
play simultaneously multiple people.
I always thought that's incredibly
hard compared to playing one game.
It's hard enough to play one.
And I must say that actually was
just a kind of a hypothesis that
led to what I do now because
as I tried to do that,
I realized that when
you're doing something
in parallel that isn't as defined
as, let's say, calculus or something.
It's not a discipline yet.
It forces you to focus on the
essence of what you're doing
and not all the idiosyncrasies
of every single case.
So I started kind of
forcibly to say, OK.
What can I do if I'm
spending a few hours a week
on a project that in and of
itself wants to change the world,
but my role in it, my involvement in it
has to be strategic, surgical, highly
leveraged, but not infinite
involvement of time, which is what
you do when you're doing one company.
And so, those experiences kind of--
So in the end, the first
company went public
and it was sold five years later.
Three of the other
companies went public.
Two of them were sold.
And this is now in '97, '98.
And eventually, I kind of
started getting more intrigued
by parallel entrepreneurship.
And I thought I would
devote myself to now going
the next step, which is to say,
if you can do this in parallel,
why not do this institutionally?
Because the next step there is, is
it a solo game or is it a team game?
And that's kind of what led to
the thinking that led to Flagship.
KARIM LAKHANI: So tell
us what Flagship does.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Yeah.
So Flagship is first and foremost
a life science innovation company.
We have our own way by which we
innovate which I'll tell you about.
Once we come up with something
that's worth taking forward,
we form a company to take that forward.
And so, we also had to
figure out how to do
venture creation in a systematic way.
We have our own capital that
we deploy into these companies
to help them grow for the
first two, three years.
So up until then, they operate as
wholly owned pieces of Flagship.
And then, we spin them out.
And we spin them out.
And for the first time,
additional capital comes in.
But by that time the culture,
the senior leadership
team, the early proof of concept,
the early kind of customer or partner
traction is there.
And it looks like a company ready to
eventually live its life on its own.
So we're not interested in building
kind of subsidiaries open endedly.
Every single thing we do ends up
becoming a company or nothing.
But so we've become kind of a creator of
companies around internal innovations.
Now, sometimes these innovations
draw from external science.
And I can describe that.
But we're not only trying
to find science, and then
find what to do with it,
and create the companies.
That has become in vogue
the last few years.
We've been doing this for 18 years.
But we've ended up in a place
where we think the sustainable
way to do this is to have your own
innovation capacity, your own company
creation capacity, initial growth, and
then the companies have the wherewithal
to grow and compete, and thrive.
KARIM LAKHANI: That's fascinating.
So walk us through one
example of a company
that you guys have given
birth to from the start
to its leaving the Flagship fold.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: There are many.
I think we've been
involved in doing about 50
of these that are based on
internally developed science.
And there's a whole bunch more
that also include external.
But I'd say one of the internally
developed ones that just recently went
public I can give as
an example is Moderna.
So Moderna was--
And I'll tell you kind of--
we have this fairly let's say prescribed
process which the way people think
about entrepreneurship and innovation,
especially breakthrough innovation,
is that it is unruly, it is
chaotic, it is uninspired, and--
KARIM LAKHANI: Serendipity.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: It's
none of those things.
KARIM LAKHANI: It's
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Absolutely
none of those things.
I have a completely
contrarian view of that.
And I've done it enough times
in enough different fields
that I think frankly, just
to be a little controversial,
I think that's an illusion.
In other words, I think that because
people haven't done that thing before,
it's exciting and unexpected to them.
But actually, pretty quickly it
looks like just another version
of what came before them because
the historians come and say,
well before there was the
iPad there was the iPod.
And before that, there was
the Walkman, et cetera.
And also, when you look at it that way,
you go, well why were you surprised?
And that's when you realize that
these things are just evolving.
And so, I'll give you an example
in this company called Moderna.
But before that I'll tell you
that underlying how we think,
you can do this
systematically, is the notion
that breakthroughs
aren't made by people.
They emerge.
And the most understood,
not well understood,
but understood version
of emergence that we
know about is evolution, which is
that if you do variation, selection
and iteration systematically,
the winners will emerge.
And when they do, they
will look surprising.
But actually they're the
result of that process.
They're not some inspired thought that
has nothing to do with that process.
So hold that thought as I give examples
that will all be examples of that.
And that actually does cause
one to think differently
about being possessive about all these
companies and all these innovations.
We're not.
We don't go around
saying, we invented this.
We may file a patent
and get an invention.
But where these ideas come
from are very emergent.
So in Moderna's case,
talking about emergence,
we understood by following the
various scientific advances
that people were playing around with
converting fibroblast cells into what's
called induced pluripotent stem cells.
These are if somebody won a
Nobel Prize recently for this,
these are called Yamanaka factors.
So it turns out that if you
take differentiated cells
and you introduce a couple of three
different proteins, four of them
specifically, these cells
can de-differentiate
and look like what came before them.
Stem cells.
They're not normal stem cells but
they're close to being stem cells.
And so, why do that?
Because then you could differentiate
it and make other cells.
So that was the general field.
And in that field, there have been some
people, particularly at UPenn and then
more recently at Children's
Hospital here in Boston,
who had been playing
around with using what's
called mRNA, messenger RNA
to use these to go into cells
and express these proteins.
Why had they done that?
Because it turns out this
mRNA, they could actually
get a better transformation
of these cells.
And so, we were aware of this work.
And we started asking kind
of just what if questions.
KARIM LAKHANI: So your team is
reading scientific papers, just
in the air, yeah.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Yeah.
Exactly.
And we do this all the time.
So and basically we're--
KARIM LAKHANI: You're in the
midst of this flow of knowledge--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Exactly.
It's not about reading
papers for us as much
as just, I mean we are
talking to lots of people
about lots of different things.
And then or somebody says, hey.
By the way, I just saw this data.
And then we actually
read papers in hindsight.
In other words, we read
papers once we have
an idea of what to do as
opposed to read papers
to get an idea per se because the
signal-to-noise in papers is gigantic.
You can't-- yeah.
If you sit there and read
1,000 papers and that
gives you three ideas,
hard to do anything else.
So I'm sure that can be done too, but
that's not the way we approach it.
Anyway, so long story short, we
started wondering for lots of reasons
that I can't almost reproduce
because you'd have to go back to 2010
in the summer and whatever else
was being thought of at the time.
So understand by that time,
we had about 20 people
that were doing this type of activity
in various combinations for a living.
And so, it's important
because these ideas kind of
get mixed and moved around.
One person thinking deeply
is not going to get there.
So we start asking,
can you think about--
we started, why is there no
drug that is based on mRNA?
Now, if you go back 10
years, drugs were made out
of proteins and small molecules.
There had been an effort to
use viruses to introduce genes
into the body called gene therapy.
And a person had died early on and
that whole field was shut down.
And there really was no other variation
to proteins and small molecules.
And there had been some efforts to
try to make, not to get too detailed,
but other small DNA, RNA
molecules, antisense what's called,
and we were aware of all this.
But we're saying, why don't people
actually use this micro-RNA molecule?
And that's just a thought experiment.
And you can go and answer that question.
KARIM LAKHANI: So you raised a problem.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: You
raise a what if problem.
Initially we don't start with,
we need to cure melanoma.
We don't start a problem, what good
is this mRNA that can transform cells?
Because it's not good for
anything other than that.
But we just kind of
abstract it and said,
is there a combination of
a solution and a problem
that we can identify
simultaneously around this space?
And if there isn't one, then we move on.
And in this case, that's
part of our methodology.
In this case, what we concluded was
that people had tried and failed
10 years earlier.
We understood why they tried and failed.
We realized that there
was no obvious fix to it.
But there was a direction of fixing
that you could modify chemically
some of these RNA molecules.
And they at least hinted
that if you kept doing that,
there may be better ways.
We had no proof.
There was no academic literature
that said this can be done.
Now we could have waited
for that but we probably
would have been five, six
years because now there
is academic papers from which
we could have started companies.
But our whole thing is to almost
mine this science of the future
to try to solve problems of today
versus mine the science of today
to solve problems of the future.
And that is exactly backwards.
And it's not any better, it's just
that you look at the world differently.
So publications give you
evidence for what you want to do.
But that's not why they
publish those things.
They were thinking of
a very different thing.
Do you know what I'm saying?
So in that regard, that's a little bit.
So in Moderna's case, we identified--
well the other thing that we do,
a very integral part of what we do
is that we don't do this in a vacuum.
So we go out and talk to
people about our hypotheses.
These are not--
KARIM LAKHANI: And you're not
afraid of people taking your ideas?
NOUBAR AFEYAN: No.
And I'll tell you why.
In order to try to
create an evolution-- so
we're trying to create an
evolutionary environment.
How do you do that?
The scientific method uses
hypotheses and experimentation.
So we actually do the same thing.
We create value hypotheses.
We basically say, I will take an mRNA
molecule formulated with this agent,
stick it into muscle, use
muscle to-- none of it is true.
None of it has been done before.
But it's just a starting point.
We then go with that to a handful
of folks that are both experts
and non-experts in the field.
Super important thing if you're
going to practice this kind of work
is that experts actually
are not the people who
are going to give you an idea
of how to do things dramatically
differently because they became experts
by already doing something dramatically
differently and now they're
defending their territory.
So if you go to talk to somebody
and say, can this be done out here?
Most people we talked
to, they can tell you
precisely why it can't be done, which
is really valuable from a selection
pressure standpoint, but
not the source of kind of,
and here's a completely different way.
So other people though
who don't have expertise
but have interesting creativity--
So what we do is we take our hypotheses.
And it's never one because one
of the things we've learned
is that if you start
with one starting point,
you only locally search
the space around it.
So we sample multiple different points.
So it might be, how about mRNA as a way
to make more proteins in a fermenter?
How about--
So around the theme, we come up
with totally different valuable
we try to identify.
And then, we put a starting
point and then we start talking.
And what has been interesting and a
great learning exercise over the years
that we've seen is that if you
go to somebody with a bad idea
but you actually present
it in a precise way,
they will tell you why it's a bad idea.
And in that transaction,
something happens.
They feel smarter and you
get selection pressure.
And so, the way our process
works is that we actually
do this with multiple people.
So when you said, aren't you afraid
they're going to take your idea?
What are they taking?
We just made it up.
There's zero fact to it.
Literally zero fact.
So--
KARIM LAKHANI: Just
imagining a hypothesis.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Exactly.
We're just a hypothesis.
And they know it.
Because then they tell us,
what proof do you have?
We say, none.
So then they still engage
because it's a almost--
when we talk to these folks, and
this is what we're known for,
we create a bit of an expert
free zone in the sense that you--
See, look.
These scientists, here we are
at Harvard, and MIT, Stanford,
these people go to the meetings of their
fields and they cannot say something
that does not seem unbelievably
smart and reasonable.
Actually I'll make the
point, let me caveat.
Reasonableness in my view
is the gravitational force
that keeps innovation from happening.
Because people enforce reasonableness
in the scientific world
on what you are allowed to say.
You go publish something
in the literature that's
not reasonable to the
reviewers, you can't publish it.
KARIM LAKHANI: You get killed.
I've done a whole study on that.
Right.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: So ask
yourself the question,
why is it that we think that the
only innovations worth working on
start their life reasonably?
In fact, I can show you many
innovations that are now
accepted as real transformative things.
Every one of them started
life unreasonably.
And yet, we go look for
them in reasonable places
by reasonable people who are using
reasonableness filters to kill them.
So because we knew that, and this
was not the first thing I had done,
we kind of say, look.
Let's forget reasonableness
for a second.
Just think with us.
And they tell us, bad idea.
Somebody in Japan had tried it.
The experiment won't work.
And we keep tweaking and
tweaking and tweaking.
This is different than kind of like
you hear a lot in Silicon Valley
speak kind of a pivoting.
This is not pivoting.
Evolution is the master pivot.
It's nonstop pivoting.
There's nothing to pivot from and to.
You're just adapting and surviving.
So that mindset is super important.
Now, what happens is over time,
things emerge or they don't.
But they emerge where the
next person you talk to goes,
they can't find fault with it.
You know that because
it frustrates them.
And then, they start telling
you, well do you have any proof?
And you go, no, no, no.
I just made this up.
It's just that we've been [INAUDIBLE]
And then, that point is when we
go into a lab for the first time.
And then and only then
do we test the idea.
Now, you can't test it fully.
You can't test it to where
it takes years and years.
But what we try to--
and one of the expertise
we've developed over the years is
how to figure out what to test first.
And this in life science, you can't
use these words killer experiment
because life science, it can kill.
But you want to do the
killer experiment early.
And so, figuring out what's the killer
experiment or two, or three, or four,
that if it doesn't fail allows you
to go forward, that's the trick.
And we do that in our shop.
So in Moderna's case, we
spent a couple million dollars
about six months doing
a set of key things
but for which we would
not have proceeded.
So we knew the idea
had morphed and evolved
and it had some resilience to it.
We went into labs and
asked specific questions.
Once we saw that actually some of
the things we were hypothesizing
could be done partially,
we then decided, OK.
Let's form the best economic value
creation engine known to mankind
which is a startup in my view.
I'm biased.
And then, we deploy that startup
to go after that value pool
in as many different ways as we can.
So that's kind of both
Moderna and the process.
So in 2010 summer, we did
what we call exploration.
We tend to start these things.
We have our own kind of terminology.
We don't start companies.
One of the things I had
learned throughout the '90s
is that companies are
kind of almost immortal.
Once you start them
it's hard to kill them.
So we thought instead of fighting
that, just don't start a company.
So we start these things
we call proto-companies.
They're prototypes.
And we don't name them.
We number them.
We don't give people titles.
And it's like a project
except it's a proto-company.
It wants to be-- just like a prototype
product, it wants to be a product.
But you can beat it up, you can
kill it, you can loan it, whatever.
That's how we work.
And we've numbered them.
We're now at, I don't know.
We've probably done about
100 of these over time.
But I think we're on number 65 because
we reset these every few years.
And so, Moderna became I think it
was 24 was the number it had, or 18.
I forget which one it was.
And then in 2011 we went into labs.
And about six months later, we started
realizing the data was functional.
We brought in, at the time, at the
early stage of the company a CEO.
Usually we get a CEO much later.
Happened to be that I
knew someone who had
kind of really interesting
experience not in doing this,
because a lot of our CEOs
have not done this before.
So we experiment with people who
have kind of more of the personality.
And we can talk about it if you like.
But in 2012 on, the company has
grown as a standalone company
and reached certain heights.
And now, today it has 21 clinical
programs of different drugs
that it's trying to develop, about
12 that have gone into humans.
And it's about 700 person company.
KARIM LAKHANI: And you had
just had an IPO as well.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: We just did an IPO.
Yes.
It has been private
work for quite a while.
But yeah.
And this is what I just described to you
is the similar case in a company called
Rubius that figured out how to take red
blood cells and make therapeutics out
of them, which nobody academically
had proposed as a therapeutic.
People were playing with red
blood cells, people were--
Again, one of the things about it
is that academic science for us
is an incredibly important
substrate that we recompose in order
to do this type of science versus--
so I'll tell you, the stark contrast,
again they both work, but is
that the way science is usually done is
money goes in to expand the boundaries.
Depending on how much money
anyone's place in the boundary
gets, how hard that terrain is,
and how insistent the person is,
that defines how quickly
that piece expands.
And over time as this expands, some
value opportunities come along.
And then, entrepreneurs
otherwise known as opportunists
in a better sense of the word,
positive sense of the word that I use,
find places where value can be created.
And they start companies.
So there's this adjacency
oriented value creation
that is science, leading to innovation,
leading to products and value.
In our case, we start with
the kind of or let's say,
foreseeing potential value.
Totally hypothetical.
Finding the appropriate
science from which
we could somehow link to that product.
And then, figuring out whether
you can get there from here.
And that allows us to
try things that look
as an illusion completely surprising.
But actually follows--
KARIM LAKHANI: [INAUDIBLE] process.
Can you give us an example
of-- so you describe Moderna
as an internally developed idea.
You've done a few that
were externally sourced.
Can you walk us through a journey like
that where you saw something and--
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Right.
And so, in that case, I mean
there's several I can give you.
But a very recent one
that we've been working on
is a company that's today
called foghorn but started
its life as a academic project where
Gerry Crabtree and Cigall Kadoch who
are experts in the field of kind of the
biochemistry of chromatin remodeling
and the protein complex that
it takes to actually that
governs aspects of regulating
expression of genes.
They had made some findings
around that complex, very, very
precise biochemistry
and molecular biology,
that had led to some
interesting findings of things
that could be drugged in targets.
Early in the field, a
lot more work to do.
But clearly we could
associate with some diseases.
By the time one of these
things gets to a place
where there's already a whole kind
of infrastructure put around it,
then you really just need capital.
I mean, you need capital with
experience but you need capital.
In this case, what to do, and how to
do it, and in what sequence to do it,
and who to do it with, all of
that is an open ended thing.
It's really more suggestive science.
The closest we get to doing
things externally is that.
And in this case, we worked
with them to come up first
without licensing the
technology or anything.
We first worked on, is
this even worth something?
So we did an exploration
that was inspired
by that starting point versus a
completely hypothetical starting point.
Still very poorly defined.
Still followed coming up
with some value hypotheses,
engaging different
discussions, iterating around,
what's the version of
this worth creating?
And then, we formed a proto-company,
tested, did some more experiments.
Now in this case, they were
experiments we could piggyback off of.
But they were as you know fully, half
of academic experiments cannot be
reproduced and do not
when they're taken.
Nothing wrong with that.
But we have to test it.
And so, we did that and we could see
that this was a really fertile space.
We attracted a team.
Some of our team went in the beginning.
And then we attracted a team.
And now, that company is emerging.
It's probably a year plus away from
having a clinical candidate to test.
But it's becoming known as a real
pioneer in that field of biology.
KARIM LAKHANI: So in this process
you describe as evolutionary process,
both for Foghorn and for
Moderna, and the general process,
you're sort of out there
doing this hypothesis testing.
How do you step away
from confirmation bias?
Which is-- how do you stop
yourselves from not fooling--
NOUBAR AFEYAN: A lot of ways.
A lot of ways.
A very good point.
So first of all, scale.
We do 100 explorations a year.
So why is that important?
Because if we did two,
we'd have a lot of bias.
But we are drowning
in things we could do.
Again, and if we open the aperture to
include external things, it'd be 1,000.
So that's not the rate limiting
step, what things to work on or not.
Second, we've carefully
designed both the team we have
and the way we reward the players
such that they're constantly
trying to figure out how quickly they
could kill an idea so they could work
on a better one which is
the exact opposite of what
happens in solo entrepreneurship
where if you kill the idea,
you're unemployed.
And while you might have another idea
to work on, you start from scratch.
So in this proto-co phase, we have many
more proto-cos than we could prosecute.
So out of the 100, maybe 10 or 15.
Not the best 10 or 15 by the way,
an absolutely arbitrary 10 or 15.
I mean it's best based on the
fit between the people who
are working on it and but we don't
have any kind of filtering process.
We do these explorations.
We have five distinct teams, each about
10 people, all PhDs, MDs, all of whom
have grown up within our infrastructure,
that in teams of two or three
do these expirations,
propose proto-companies.
Then a handful of them get
taken into proto-company phase.
Each one gets a million to $2 million.
And then, they run the
gauntlet of proving it wrong.
One way you get no confirmation
bias is that everybody
knows that if they're
working on this, they're
not working on the next Moderna
or the next Rubius, or--
So it's not perfect.
And of course, there's the third
element is that people like me
and many others now who
have done this for 15,
20 years in the Flagship
context, we're 18 years old now,
are there to kind of keep
reminding people that they
should question themselves.
I mean, one of the things I
kind of deduced, everybody
who does this long enough comes
up with their own kind of words
to say similar things.
In my case, the mindset that I think
saves you from this kind of bias
as much as possible is that
of a paranoid optimist.
And so, I for a long time
tried to get across this notion
that if you're going
to be in this space,
if you're a paranoid optimist--
by that I mean you're not
so optimistic that you
actually get reckless,
but you're not so paranoid
that you get depressed.
And this constantly questioning
whether it really will work,
or how big it will be,
or whether you should
be doing something else,
that doubt, doubtful optimism
which is really a tortured state
to be in, is perfect for evolution.
It makes you poised.
It makes you constantly
say, but can I do it better?
Can I do differently?
Who else is doing it?
And so, that is a fourth way maybe
of protecting against the bias,
is that we could not
believe in what we're
saying long enough because
the doubt constantly kicks in.
And then, we don't stay
doubtful long enough
that we don't actually take some risk.
So it's really it's like a
gas pedal and a brake pedal.
You don't want to press
them at the same time.
But if you toggle between them and
you've got a steering wheel, at least
simplistically I think
you can go places.
KARIM LAKHANI: For the
people taking our course,
they won't have access to a Flagship.
They'll be around the world.
They'll have access to some technology.
And they'll have to sort of
develop these value hypotheses.
What advice would you give them?
So they're come across
something from our course,
or something in their own
companies, or in the labs,
or the universities near them.
And what advice would you
give them in terms of how
to follow your process on their own?
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Of course.
Of course.
No, and in fact, I think they can.
I think some of what we do has
to do with the institution.
But a lot of what we do is
a mindset and a methodology.
And that is not dependent
on the institution.
So I'd say first and foremost
again, everything I'm saying
has to do with science based
companies because there's
a lot of other companies that are market
based and product innovation based
and execution based that a lot of
this stuff is maybe overkill for.
KARIM LAKHANI: Yeah.
I don't think there will
be any apps in our--
So a science based company,
I'd say a few things.
One, you've got to ask
yourself whether you really
believe that the solution should emerge
versus the solution should be asserted
and that you just have to
go look for an application.
I believe that if you
really think rigorously,
you may have a technology for which you
try to find a problem worth solving.
But then that problem
may be better solved
with something else
which you might also be
able to go get which might
lead you to another problem.
And those iteration loops might get
you a lot more of a valuable place
than just saying, I'm a matchmaker.
This technology.
This application.
I'm done.
So first is if you really want
to dedicate the next five, 10
years of your life, which in
life science is a short frame.
And in the tech world, it's two years.
It works, doesn't work, you're out.
So that's one thing is I'd say
think about your own version
of an emergent process.
And don't prematurely stop
variation, stop selection.
And by the way, don't also just
outsource selection to investors
because if you're an
entrepreneur and you say,
I will come up with the solution.
And then, let's see
what they'll invest in.
You'll be optimizing
for investability, not
for what's worth building, what's going
to make the biggest reward for you,
society, what's impactful.
It'll purely be custom made
to those days' investors.
And by the way, the reason
people get frustrated
is that every investor is
looking for a different thing.
And so, they think it's noise.
And they can't get selection
pressure out of it.
I think that's a good thing.
They should themselves get
selection pressure from customers,
from people who are going to actually
prescribe the medicine, or patients,
or a combination of things.
So that's one set of things.
I think the second thing that
this mindset gives you is,
and we haven't talked about this.
So let me just bring that
out, is that every one
of these kind of company
ideas, big breakthroughs,
could be technology out of labs.
And by the way, I think it's a
perfectly good starting point.
You want to think about it in its
ultimate embodiment as possibly
many, many different companies.
So a seed that can give rise to--
I mean think of almost a fertilized egg.
That is an omnipotent cell when
it comes to differentiation.
It could make liver cells,
it could make cardiac cells,
it could make immune cells,
it can go many different ways.
So if you think about all those ways,
if you think about all those ways,
then you have to ask yourself,
how long can I keep optionality
even while I'm building value?
Because if you just sit
there and go, oh my God.
I could be anything,
you don't do anything.
But the question becomes, if I have
direction A that locks me into becoming
a skin cell and that's it, I'm done.
Or a cell that can still
maintain optionality.
If you're in a brand new space,
you really want to first, up front,
think about all the different versions
of a Moderna that could be created.
And maybe you can't build the
biggest version on day one.
But choices you make that
preserve the biggest version,
keeps it alive for the longest
time, probably the best way
to make decisions.
Very hard otherwise.
Everybody who succeeds
tells the story as
though it was strategically thoughtful.
The reality is you know, I know,
and everybody who tells the truth
knows that these
companies are the result
of a whole lot of accidental decisions
and some thoughtful decisions.
So I just think you also want
to be cynical about thinking
that thoughtfulness, and
reasonableness, and advice
is going to get you the answer.
Really, you just want
to keep optionality.
KARIM LAKHANI: So and
I think what you said
which was so interesting to me
was this notion that you start
with a technology, you find
a problem, but then you
might find a related problem, and then
you might find something even bigger,
and you might find a
different technology.
So these technologies that
we give to our students
are almost like starting points.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Absolutely.
KARIM LAKHANI: It's a starting point for
that evolutionary process to kick in.
[INAUDIBLE]
NOUBAR AFEYAN: And again, it could
be frustrating to be honest with you
because if you're, you know--
KARIM LAKHANI: Well, there's a
lot of dead bodies in evolution.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Well, that's true.
That's true.
That's absolutely--
But I think if you say,
I don't like the odds of evolution.
Therefore, I'd rather subject
myself to a pure dead filter.
A dead filter is kind of
something-- a filter basically
is you put a bunch of things and
whatever gets through gets through.
Evolution, there is no filter.
It's a selection process.
It's dynamic.
But either way, there's going
to be a selection of some sort.
I would argue that in this
version, what if you survive,
my guess is that you will be
doing something worth doing.
In this other case, if
you survive you might just
be able to raise money or
somebody buys you early on.
So I think it's OK.
But you got to almost
prepare yourself for it.
And it's not--
And to your point, I mean problem
discovery and solution probleming
are interesting iterative loops.
The way I describe it to people is
think of yourself as an insurgent.
We all know that in every
field there's incumbents.
And these incumbents
innovate in a particular way.
They keep expanding what they're
dominant incumbents zone is ever
so gradually.
And you come in as an insurgent.
You don't have capital
as your advantage,
you don't have brand
as your advantage, you
don't have networks as your advantage.
But man, you have one advantage.
And that is it doesn't matter
to you what problem you
solve with what solution.
As long as you can create
value, you make progress.
And that's the advantage
of an insurgent.
What happens is oftentimes
people lose that advantage
and they force themselves
to just do one thing.
And I just I think that that insurgent
mindset is really, really important.
KARIM LAKHANI: That's so cool.
So say a bit more about
the selection pressures
that people should put themselves
under around their ideas.
So the mechanism you talked about is
talking about experts and non-experts,
people knowledgeable in the field
but not necessarily deep experts
in those fields.
What else?
What else should they be
doing in this early stage
where there are some technology, some
notion of a problem to be solved,
and then some hypothesis or
hypotheses that they might have?
How do they increase the
selection pressure on--
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Yeah.
I mean this is the trickiest part.
I should say that when I say experts and
non-experts, these can be in academia,
these could be in startups, these
could be in larger companies.
There's a massive
amount of networking one
has to do so that they get to
talk to interesting people who
will have a point of view
about what they're doing.
It is a scary thing to give people your
most cherished kind of notion which
you think is the beginnings of the
next Apple computer and the next Google
when in fact it's just an
idea you had, whatever.
So even if the technology has
been developed-- by the way,
companies that are based
on a certain technology,
either you have patents that
cover technology or you don't.
If you don't, then you
should go file some patents
and if it's truly an invention.
And if you say, well where do I
get the money to file the patents?
Well that's all, of course,
on startup fundraising.
But let's assume you've got the
ability at least to have patents.
So if there are patents, then you
don't have to describe the patents
and enable people.
You just have to say, I've got this
patented technology that can do X.
And if somebody says,
well, how does it work?
You can say look, I'm happy
to tell you how it works.
But let me first tell you what it does.
And tell me whether what
it does is worth doing.
And if they say about how does it
work, there's no logic that says,
unless I know how it works I can't tell
you whether what you're proposing to do
is worth doing.
That's not true.
And the other thing we've
learned over the years
is how to describe your
maybe invention or idea
in ways that are
analogous to what you're
doing, not exactly what you're doing,
but that share the effect in common.
Does that make sense?
I'm going to invent a digital camera.
And I want to find out if
cameras under water are useful.
Well I can take a non-digital
camera and I can say to you,
hey how about this camera under water?
And if they say, well,
how is it going to work?
It's not digital.
And you say, look let's
assume I'm doing it.
You still don't have to tell
them you've got a digital camera.
You can give them an analog that has the
same problem it's trying to go after.
Get feedback.
Conversely for problem
people, you want to give them
a sense of the solution
you have and see how they--
so it's a little tricky.
It may sounds a little complicated.
Frankly, I think people do this anyway.
They just do it out of
desperation because they just
keep trying, and trying,
and trying, and trying.
And all everything I've
said ends up being tried.
It's not like we came up
with it because I derived it
from what I had been doing.
It's just that I'm saying, be
thoughtful about that being the act of--
It's funny I should mention to you
in a more kind of abstract way.
Years ago, when I started teaching
at Sloan this course in 2000,
and they wanted me to teach
a course on entrepreneurship.
And I thought, well you
can't teach entrepreneurship.
You can maybe learn it.
But you can't teach it.
And I realized I had this problem
with the word entrepreneurship.
And I'll tell you to your
audience anyway because I
don't want to miss the chance.
So first problem with
the word entrepreneurship
is that any word that's French is
kind of a little bit ostentatious
or whatever.
So there's the old joke.
What's the difference
between a vase and a vase?
About $500.
So entrepreneur is kind of this--
Now there's an ironic comment I'll make
about entrepreneurs since the audience
is an entrepreneur by definition,
is that it actually comes
from the French word to undertake which
is kind of ironic because that means
literally undertaker which is kind of
unfortunately where we find ourselves
often as entrepreneurs, is you're
kind of dealing with undertaking
in the other meaning of the word.
But the more serious part
of what I want to say
is this part, which is what I don't
like is the ending of the word.
So ship as the ending
of a word in English
often means the state
of being something.
Craftsmanship, leadership,
friendship, sportsmanship.
All these ships mean the
state of being something.
Now I'm an engineer.
I don't do engineer-ship.
KARIM LAKHANI: You do engineering.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: I do engineering
which is the act of doing something.
And what I really find is an unfortunate
remnant of the history of this field
is that people are thought to be
something versus do something.
And therefore, they spend all their time
trying to analyze the history, the DNA,
the character of people who do this.
Whereas, I think at
some point, people are
going to realize that a lot of
different kinds of people can do this.
But the this is entrepreneuring.
It's not entrepreneurship.
And as soon as society
flips that, which is
by the way happening right around us.
All these incubators, mentor services,
all these accelerates, all of these
are-- but when I started 20 years
ago, that was not at all in vogue.
And I actually--
KARIM LAKHANI: It was a crazy people
who were doing entrepreneurship
or the people that weren't
so good at school, right?
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Exactly.
There were attention deficit,
people who couldn't get a job.
It was kind of the funny field.
And then when it succeeded
people celebrate it.
That's the other thing I'll say
is it's great to celebrate things.
But after a while, you got
to stop celebrating this.
Because it shouldn't be this rare
and it shouldn't be this hard.
The reason it is is that
people often tell themselves,
this is like a lottery.
It's not going to work.
And they do it without
a lot of forethought.
And that's I think why courses like
this really should get people to say,
I could do it by winging it.
But do I want to actually have
as my profession improvisation?
I mean, if you want to do
that you can be a comedian,
you can be a jazz musician.
But the notion that you're
going to improvise for a living
and then take unsuspecting
people's money, and then let alone
make something you put
into patients to save them.
Just think about the juxtaposition
of how we do entrepreneurship
and what we do in entrepreneurship.
Pretty big difference.
So I think, I mean I'm
very happy that I'm
living long enough to see this
field literally become a profession.
And the reason I used to call
parallel entrepreneurship
is because it was kind of so ironic.
What does it mean to do
parallel-- you can be one thing.
How can you be parallel
entrepreneurship, right?
But once something becomes a profession,
I think this is going to be--
I think my kids who
are in their 20s now,
but the next generation who
does this, this will be more
like a profession like
medicine, architecture,
versus this sideshow that's celebrated
and people are getting movies made,
and they're going to
get rich quick scheme.
It's going to be a profession.
KARIM LAKHANI: Yeah.
Two questions for you.
Well, first one.
One question for you is around.
We're fortunate to be at MIT and
Harvard, graduates from those schools,
and so forth.
And our networks are deep and
it's easy for us to access people.
We just say, oh, alum from
this school or so forth.
Others aren't from those schools.
How do they build networks?
How do they access
networks when they may not
have the brand labels attached to them?
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Well I mean of
course brand labels are one thing,
physical location is one thing.
Look, there's no--
I don't have a special insight to that.
I recognize that that is--
I mean not doing it isn't a possibility
here, but figuring out how to do it,
I think it's--
at the end of the day,
relationships lead to relationships.
And wherever you are, being
connected to some thought leaders--
I mean first of all, I'd say
that around the world, people
who are the top in their field yes both
have other colleagues in that field,
but also are recognized for
being top in their field
and therefore can open
doors to any other field.
So I would look for somebody
who's top in a field
even though that's not
what I'm working on
and see if I can develop a relationship
through whom can get some credibility
to be able to break into this.
If you can actually go to a place where
there's people who have expertise,
it's really a question of
just persistence, persistence.
I don't know if some
magic way of doing it.
There's people who are great networkers.
I'm not one of them, by the way.
So whatever success I've
had has been despite that.
It took me a long time to even say
hello to David Packard 30 something
years ago.
So the other thing you got to
do, and this is a good segue,
is look, you're not doing this alone.
And so, part of the reason
to have an early team
is that there will be
other personalities.
And so, if you're not
that but there is somebody
who's that, their value is immense
provided that they're not sitting
there saying, oh what's the product?
What's the science?
And they may be out saying,
how do I create relationships
so that we can actually get
the idea exposed, get feedback?
By the way, and I said earlier, the more
you make yourself needy and accepting
of their input, the more
they'll be willing to do it.
It's what I've seen.
So don't go in there and make
pronouncements and kind of say,
we've solved this problem.
I mean, I've long thought that this
whole culture of 30 second elevator
pitches, and quick business
plans, and value propositions,
and executive summaries,
juxtaposed to something that's
completely unprecedented, I'm sorry.
It's laughable.
I mean, it's cute.
But then somebody really just
wants to say, what's the big idea?
And why do you think
you can work on this?
And why you?
Why this?
Why now?
Those are the three questions.
And if you just get
people to say, look, I
don't know exactly how
I'm going to do this.
So stay a little vulnerable.
KARIM LAKHANI: Yeah.
Especially the early stage, right?
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Exactly.
Exactly.
And even later on.
Look, you're always the earlier
stage of what you want to become.
So I actually would advise
not to become later stage.
I think you want to stay early stage.
Moderna is an early stage company.
Moderna wants to have 10 drugs
in 10 different therapeutic areas
10 years from now.
So what is it compared to that?
Nothing.
Early stage.
That keeps you in that mode of
constantly looking up versus saying,
wow look how far I got.
I must know something.
The worst thing you could do is to think
you look down the mountain and say,
I must know how to climb
because look at where I am.
Bad idea.
KARIM LAKHANI: Let's
just talk about your view
about this or the systematic
nature of innovation
and how it can be systematized.
What advice, again, would you
give to our course participants
around how to flip their mind
away from the lottery perspective
to the systematic perspective?
How should they reorient their own
thinking around the systematic nature?
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Yeah.
No.
I mean, look.
I think it's tricky because every other
impetus we get about entrepreneurship
reinforces the lottery mentality.
It's television shows,
there's this, that.
And frankly I hate it because people
also describe their success story--
KARIM LAKHANI: As a lottery.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: In that way.
It's literally like saying I
can dunk because I'm 7 foot 8".
Well what am I supposed to do with that?
It often isn't true.
But in any case, people
describe it as this fantasy.
By the way, parenthetically
I'll mention one thing
just because it may
resonate with some people.
Any journey in hindsight can be
described in a very different way
than it was actually prosecuted.
A good example of that is a chess game.
In the beginning, there's a massive
range of things you could do.
At the very end, there's only
a few things you could do.
And if you look at the game backwards,
the game looks entirely different.
Every decision you take now
informs your interpretation
of how you made that decision which
is not how you made the decision.
That is why a lot of people
tell entrepreneurship,
or for that matter innovation
journeys not accurately at all.
Because that they don't describe it
the way they were thinking about it.
So that's just a thought.
So your question about how do they think
more systematically about it, again,
I would say keep an adaptive
evolutionary mindset.
Try this kind of variation selection.
You might ask, how long do you iterate?
Because you keep iterating forever,
you're never going to do anything.
So there's this kind of
difference between what's possible
and what's real.
And kind of you got to extract
some reality out of it.
But I think I don't have
kind of rules of thumb.
I'd say don't get trapped into
thinking that all you need to do
is to find a best use case
for something that exists.
You can do that.
By the way, if you go
through all of this and you
find that the first thing you thought
of is the most valuable thing, great.
You'll be well served because
if it turns out not to be,
you have other things to do.
So this was not a waste of time.
But if you think your
job is to find that one
thing as though there
is one thing, that's
where you get into a lottery trap.
I long ago, this will kind of maybe
revolt people to hear me say it,
but I hope they take it with
a bit of a grain of salt.
Long ago, somebody when I first
came to MIT, use the expression
that the lottery is a tax on
the mathematically impaired.
KARIM LAKHANI: Yes.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: And if you just
stop and think about it, in reality
there's no version of a
lottery that makes any--
and yet we do it because we're
human beings and we're optimists
and we think that we can beat the odds.
There's an element of a lottery that's
always going to be there with startups.
An element.
What I call a leap of faith.
There's a leap of faith which says,
I can reason my way to this point.
I want to do something that's a
little further or a lot further.
I have to leap.
That, we're never going to take away.
I'm not advocating that
because it's contrary
to my reasonableness discussion before.
However, when you say,
well, it's a lottery anyway.
So why not buy 10 tickets?
Why not get all my earnings
and put it into the lottery?
That level of kind of trying to
rationalize that there's some--
that's dangerous.
And I think this field,
a lot of failures,
you've probably studied this
a lot better than I have.
But a lot of failures in
startups I think are avoidable.
And some are not.
Now, we report on the data on both.
And I think over time, the
first category should diminish.
The other has to do with
uncertainty, and competition,
and all sorts of things we're
not going to get away from.